[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec à la une une
alternative à l'essence avec la flambée
des prix à la pompe certains
automobiliste se tourner vers le bio
éthanol moins cher mais est ce une si
bonne idée vosges télévision nous
donnera quelques éléments de réponse dès
le début de ce journal quelle image on
les artistes intellectuels journalistes
de notre pays c'est la question posée
par l'éditorialiste yves thréard à douze
personnalités les entretiens riches
réunis dans un ouvrage paru aux éditions
du rocher que nous fera découvrir
christophe rigaud une immersion rare
aussi dans ce journal dans l'atelier du
créateur christian louboutin c'est là
que lui et son équipe s'attelle à créer
des talons unique pour les clients et
clientes prestigieuse plutôt une plongée
dans le secret louboutin avec la
rédaction de monaco info il est l'unique
phare classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco le phare de cordouan est de
nouveau ouvert au public 9 à l'est de
travaux ont redonné sa splendeur au site
comme a pu le constater la rédaction de
télé 7 à bordeaux comment réduire sa
facture énergétique et ainsi faire des
économies
une question à laquelle sont confrontés
de nombreux ménages depuis quelques
semaines et particulièrement les
automobilistes car face à la hausse des
prix à la pompe certains sont tentés de
se tourner vers de nouveaux carburants
et à ce jeu là le bioéthanol a de quoi
séduire vous allez le voir avec son prix
compétitif
de nombreux français n'hésitent pas à
installer un kit nécessaire pour ce
carburant sur leur voiture mais est ce
vraiment une bonne idée éléments de
réponse avec hélène le plat de la
rédaction de vos jeux télévision
regarder
avec la flambée des prix à la pompe
nombreux sont ceux qui cherchent une
alternative en dessous de 1 euro le
litre l'éthanol entendent plus d'un boom
exponentielle de la demande
d'installation de boîtiers bioéthanol
qui permettent de modifier un moteur
essence et ainsi changer de carburant
les informations du fabricant lui-même
600% de commandes en plus chez nous à
notre niveau on va dire on va pas
exagérer c'était
quatre fois cinq fois plus que la
normale pour répondre à la demande de ce
garage a décidé de former un mécanicien
il lui faut environ trois heures pour
adapter un véhicule on fait attention à
l'emplacement du boîtier il faut pas
qu'il soit après deux jours de chaleur
et pour les faisceaux c'est pareil faut
que ça soit faut pas que ça soit près
d'une source de chaleur si c'est un
hymne riz il faut pas que ça soit près
des fils haute tension conclusion sur la
vingtaine de garage contacter seuls 3
propose ce service à noter que 20% du
parc automobile pourrait supporter ce
type de modification
l'importance ça déjà voir l'état du
véhicule parce que les véhicules
forcément tuant hic c'est qu'il est m on
ne prendra pas le risque de poser parce
que aussi sceptique d'avoir une usure
déjà anormal de deux véhicules lisa par
ford la plupart des constructeurs ne
développe pas de véhicule à l'éthanol
intégrer cette concession reçoit des
directives qui incite à la méfiance
allant jusqu'à annuler la garantie
constructeur en cas de modification au
modifié quand même
le véhicule on modifie les informations
de la carte grise donc c'est quand même
pas neutre une transformation ça vaut
entre 700 et 1000 500 sur certains
modèles civic à nole est si attractif à
la pompe alors qu'il coûte plus cher à
fabriquer c'est qu'il n'est presque pas
taxées créé à partir de productions
agricoles betteraves et céréales pour
85% ils rejettent peu de co2 une vertu
mise en avant par les pouvoirs publics
la région grand est fournie n'est de 550
euros pour des véhicules qu'on peut de
quatre ans coût moyen en rivière ses 800
euros ttc avec la pause elle le quitte
donc la clé de la région normande donc
ça ça revient à peu près de 150 euros de
la peau du client
plus de trois semaines après la levée
des principales restrictions et alors
que sa circulation est encore active le
coronavirus semble être un lointain
souvenir pour de nombreux français en
martinique les habitants sont de retour
en masse dans les bars dans les boîtes
de nuit depuis la fin du couvre-feu le
1er avril dernier celui ci était en
vigueur depuis le 13 juillet 2021 soit
pendant plus de huit mois une libération
bien sûr et forcément les professionnels
de la restauration de l'événementiel
sont contents les martiniquais eux sont
heureux de se retrouver pour faire la
fête un sujet de atv martinique sur
place
à l'occasion de la fin du couvre-feu ces
rugbymen venus tout droit de saint
barthélemy viennent profiter de
l'ambiance martiniquaise
on est venu ici parce que là c'est la
fin du couvre-feu
fini le couvre-feu à 22h on revient sur
les horaires habituels ce qui permet par
exemple d'enchaîner les événements
et c'est vrai
en vigueur depuis le 13 juillet 2021
soit plus de huit mois la levée du
couvre-feu est une véritable libération
pour les professionnels du monde de la
nuit un soulagement oui bien sûr c'est
autant pour nous que pour les clients
donc de plus avant cette pression de
dîners rapidement devenir s'amuser
rapidement donc
et en plus de ce soulagement demain je
dirais aussi financier car malgré les
aides de l'état aujourd'hui on avait du
mal à bien sûr à finir les mois
avec des couvre-feux en temps si la
plupart des confrères on se retrouve
dans des situations on n'était pas prêt
à ça beaucoup le manque beaucoup de
libération mais passer de stable à
l'heureuse manger beaucoup de personnel
sont en fait des reconversions et la
semaine prochaine s'annonce encore plus
chargé avec cette fois la suspension du
pass à nanterre thierry beaudet était
l'invité de l'émission face aux
territoires jeudi sur tv5monde
le président du conseil économique
social et environnemental le céser la
troisième assemblée française a
notamment évoqué le rôle que devraient
jouer les territoires durant le prochain
quinquennat
écoutez ce qu'il a dit
175 mans qui sont originaires de toutes
les régions françaises on peut le dire
les territoires ultramarins qui nous
écoutent sont évidemment eux aussi
représentée au sein du conseil
économique social et environnemental
oui si c'est une spécificité six membres
pour représenter les territoires
ultramarins mais comme vous l'avez dit
les les organisations qui sont présentes
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
désigne des membres venant de tout tout
notre pays a la droit à la fois dans
l'hexagone et dans les territoires qu'on
peut dire l'émission face aux
territoires avec thierry baudet le
président du conseil économique social
et environnemental est à voir ou à
revoir sur les sites internet de
tv5monde de nice-matin de ouest france
et de 20 minutes c'est les partenaires
de cette émission le reste de
l'actualité marquée ces derniers jours
par des températures glaciales sur une
bonne partie de la france même si les
températures sont remontés ces derniers
jours les conséquences de cette vague de
froid et claire sont importantes sur les
cultures les arboriculteurs notamment en
touche et dans le sud ouest de la france
exemple à moissac dans le tarn et
garonne où ce producteur estime avoir
perdu près de 70% de sa récolte de
prunes est une mauvaise nouvelle
évidemment qui s'ajoutent aux pertes
déjà constatées l'an dernier pour lui le
dérèglement climatique est en cause
écoutez le au micro de jean marc lucas
pour vient occitanie l'a envoyé ces deux
brunes là vous voyez comme un seul noir
el sol gelé celle là voyez que les
vertes elle n'est pas gelé toutes les
prunes qui était sorti de coiffure sont
gelés il ya dix jours il avait 22 23
degrés 1 un jour alors la végétation a
explosé et après c'était du froid qui
arrivait du nord du nord la france
s'était pas dégelé de matin c'était des
jeux et noir qu'on appelle hélas et
désolés catastrophique pour lui un froid
dévastateur pour ce producteur
d'occitanie qui concerne aussi bien
d'autres territoires dans l'aube par
exemple les vignes de champagne ont
subit elle aussi les effets du gel alors
pour tenter de limiter les dégâts
certains producteurs ont recours à la
méthode dite de l'aspersion celle ci
permet comme vous le voyez sur ces
images de nos partenaires de l'est
éclair de créer des poches de glace
autour des bourgeons et d'éviter ainsi
leur gel durant la chute des
températures
tout à fait autre chose à présent dans
ce grand jt des territoires
connaissez-vous la dôle thérapie ce nom
ne vous dit peut être rien pourtant sa
pratique se répand dans les
établissements pour personnes âgées le
principe est simple susciter des
émotions chez les patients atteints de
troubles cognitifs grâce à l' usage de
poupées ultra réaliste ces résultats
sont immédiatement visible sur les
concernés regardez cet exemple dans un
ehpad du mans avec ce reportage de diane
le moisson pour ahlem tv dans la sarthe
c'est un joli moment inattendu plein de
douceur qui a été proposé ce lundi à
l'ehpad public irène joliot curie du
mans avec des résidents atteints de
troubles cognitifs type alzheimer l'
approche non médicamenteuse est
privilégiée on multiplie donc ici les
billets de médiation comme les animaux
les robots les stimulations sensorielles
aujourd'hui c'est la proche avec des
poupées qui est testé la tôle thérapie
les effets ils sont révélés dans le
cadre des études mais ils sont vraiment
visible au quotidien mais tout de suite
il ya des soignants qui pleure un
vraiment en voyant la réaction de
certaines personnes la réaction c'est
l'étonnement la surprise
l'émerveillement
le bien-être la détente et puis le fait
de parler beaucoup aussi de trouver les
mots des mots qui sortent tout seul
alors qu'elle les personnes qui ne
parlent plus depuis plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années
elle revient à andré base de
la bagarre de rue
les poupées réalistes sont peintes à la
main par adeline à partir de moulages de
vrais bébés si ici on poupe est
volontiers il n'est pas question
d'infantilisation on n'invite pas une
personne âgée à jouer à la poupée quand
on lui présente une poupée pas du tout
faits n'a rien à voir ici un peu une
poupée aussi belle soit elle n'est pas
en jouer c'est un objet qui attire
l'attention et qui génèrent des émotions
des souvenirs et qui est vecteur de lien
social et à travers cette poupée il peut
se passer plein plein de choses à partir
du moment où la personne est intéressée
où elle est sensible à la proche
du rire des larmes beaucoup d'émotion
tout cas les résidences sont repartis
ravis de cette expérience
voilà des images touchantes venue du
mans non sans lien avec une autre
initiative déployer cette fois ci en
région parisienne envers les plus petits
dans les yvelines des étudiants en
médecine ont rencontré des enfants et
leur nounours le temps d'une
consultation
l'objectif désacraliser le monde de la
santé grâce à la prise en charge de
leurs peluches et tout petits se sont
vus aussi remettre un certificat de
nounoursologues un sujet et une nouvelle
profession expliqué par la rédaction de
télé 78 dans les villes
[Musique]
il a trois ans j'ai dû beau petit chou
est un petit patient un peu étrange il
fait partie des nombreuses peluches aux
maladies imaginaires venus accompagnés
de leurs amis de jeunes enfants 2,50
[Musique]
ils arrivent ils nous disent le nom de
leurs doudous leur âge leur taille etc
on prend les constantes on l'est pèse on
leur demande quelle maladie longs et
après du coup on va pouvoir les emmener
au bloc opératoire où ils vont pouvoir
basse habiller un peu comme les vrais
sur gien puis on va alors leur montrer
d'esserent qu'on peut faire pour sauver
le doubs après on les amène à la
pharmacie donc là on a fabriqué des
petits médicaments défaut pour que
puissent vraiment prendre conscience de
ce que ça médicaments la salle du vieux
marché à jouy en josas a pris le temps
d'une journée la lure d'un hôpital pour
nounours une quinzaine d'élèves en
deuxième année de médecine à
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines organise ces cessions dans
plusieurs villes des yvelines chaque
année une façon pour les enfants de
découvrir le monde médical d'une autre
façon on va endormir doudou comme ça il
aura pas mal pendant qu'on va réparer
son bras d'accord si justement pour les
sensibiliser déjà au milieu médical pour
qu'ils aient moins peur pour que quant à
eux ils seront emmenés aller chez le
médecin il ait confiance que ce qu'en
général les enfants ils sont un petit
peu free et surtout par les blouses
blanches parce qu'ils connaissent pas
trop mais là le fait de les avoir vus en
amont avec leur doudou ça leur fera mon
père cohésion à l'hôpital où je comme
chez le médecin généraliste et pour les
étudiants de se former à communiquer
avec les plus petits on va souvent
l'adulte et je conseille par bien
d'avoir un peu une approche les enfants
parce que c'est pas la même chose ils
comprennent pas pareil faut agir
différemment et entre les différents
mots attribués aux peluches par les
enfants une thématique semble revenir
plus que les autres
il ya un combinant oui mais que personne
ne s'inquiète tout lé nounours ont été
soignés à la fin les enfants se sont vus
chacun attribuer un diplôme de
nounoursologues pour en témoigner un
suivi des patients se fera ensuite dans
leur classe avec leurs professeurs
en pleine campagne présidentielle
quelles idées se fait-on de la france
d'aujourd'hui
la question mérite d'être posée elle est
l'objet du dernier livre de
l'éditorialiste yves thréard intitulé
une certaine idée de la france le
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
figaro s'est entretenu avec douze
personnalités du monde des idées de
droite comme de gauche un ouvrage
passionnant qui nous livre xii regard
très aiguisé sur notre pays
christophe rigaud a rencontré yves
thréard pour évoquer avec lui son
ouvrage regarder
ils sont intellectuels journalistes
artistes et tous ont une certaine idée
de la france d'après l'expression du
général de gaulle reprise par yves
thréard pour sa série d'entretiens
diffusée par la chaîne parlementaire
mais aujourd'hui ces rencontres font
l'objet d'un livre est ce qui a surpris
le journaliste c'est l'optimisme de nos
intellectuels ce qui m'a étonné alors
qu'on est dans une période où
on est souvent très nostalgique du passé
à peu déprimé et bien ce qui est assez
intéressant c'est de voir que ce que
j'ai interviewés ne sont pas ne sombre
pas dans le pessimisme
il reste optimiste sur l'avenir et sont
persuadés que la france évidemment un
rôle à jouer ils sont persuadés que la
france a encore des ressources pour
et bien pour surmonter les difficultés
pour faire face aux défis qui se posent
à elle en ce 21ème siècle 12 regard sur
la france qui vont au delà des clivages
politiques ce clivage gauche droite il
existe évidemment il est toujours là
mais il est aussi je dirais accompagné
conjuguer avec d'autres clivages qui
sont les clivages plus ou moins par
exemple on est plus ou moins ouverts sur
l'extérieur
vous en avez qui sont très
centralisateur d'autres questions sont
beaucoup moins derrière l' ouvrage
d'yves thréard il y a une maison
d'édition les éditions du rocher qui
défendent la place du livre dans le
débat d'idées quand on voit la brièveté
des messages sur les réseaux sociaux la
manière dont seront menées
malheureusement beaucoup de débats
télévisuels ou radiophoniques on
s'aperçoit que le livre reste quand même
un outil privilégié pour exprimer une
pensée la développer la construire et la
faire partager que je crois que le livre
est un véritable outil pour se créer une
réflexion de fond pour créer une
réflexion de fond l'alimenter alimenter
ce débat les idées et je crois que c'est
un outil qui permet à celui qui
l'utilisent de rester libre face à
l'argument qui lui est assénée à l'heure
où les français s'apprêtent à élire leur
président et leur présidente de la
république ces entretiens peuvent aider
le lecteur et le citoyen à aiguiser son
esprit critique
voilà et élise et sa curiosité cela
passe aussi par l'apprentissage explique
l économie via deux courtes vidéos c'est
l'objectif du concours trois minutes
pour comprendre un concours national
organisé par l'association des
professeurs de sciences économiques et
sociales auxquelles participent des
classes du lycée de balagne haute corse
après des semaines de création de vidéos
ont été sélectionnés et sont présentées
sur youtube le groupe dont la vidéo
réalisera le plus de like remportera ce
concours aussi pédagogique que connectés
proposé explications recueillies au
micro de pierre pasqualini de la
rédaction de via télé pas aisée en corse
c'est un concours d'économie qu'on a
réalisé grâce à la professeur d'économie
qui nous a proposé en octobre environ
c'est un concours national donc c'est
faire une vidéo sur une notion
économique on a choisi le
protectionnisme ça nous semblait
attirant et puis c'était une notion
qu'on avait très bien compris en cours
donc on pensait que la représentant dans
une vidéo ça serait pas un problème il
faut tout préparer à l'avancé et
seulement ensuite passer à la vidéo et
après au montage et aux voix on espère
aller loin on espère aller très loin
mais ça va être compliqué parce que on
est devant des grands lycées des très
grands lycées en france de l'économie
aux sports dans ce grand jt des
territoires en savoie 600 collégiens ont
bénéficié d'une sortie scolaire pas
comme les autres ils ont profité des
joies de la glisse dans un bobsleigh sur
la piste olympique de la plagne rien que
ça à l'approché des jeux olympiques de
paris 2024 c'est un événement qui a pour
but de promouvoir les valeurs du sport
en france ainsi de la journée à tous des
tests dans ce reportage de luca ruch
pour la rédaction de 8 mont blanc
une fois le casque enfiler les voilà fin
prêt ces collégiens savoyard s'apprête à
dévaler les un kilomètre et demi de
descente de la piste de bobsleigh de la
plagne une fois lancé le bob raft
composée de 4 personnes prend petit à
petit de la vitesse pour atteindre
jusqu'à 80 kilomètres heure loin de leur
salle de classe ces élèves prennent
rapidement ou aux sensations fortes et à
l'arrivée les affichent tous un large
sourire c'était super bien franchement
art fair à refaire les sorties scolaires
comme ça c'est pas tous les jours
et c'est bien c'est bien d'avoir 16 ans
le collège je n'étais pas crier toulon
j'ai crié j'ai créé le monde il va que
j'aime invité par le département ces
collégiens ont participé à la première
étape de la trace des champions d'ici
aux jeux olympiques 2000 24,6 rendez
vous comme celui ci seront proposés en
savoie les élèves ont d'ailleurs pu
échanger avec certains athlètes
olympiques ravis de partager leur
passion hyper contents ils ont le
sourire ils sont motivés ils sont
intéressés donc c'est vraiment plaisir
de faire découvrir notre spa j'ai quand
même bien les souvenirs que j'ai
de
quoi bien avec mes potes
rencontrer des athlètes
une chouette expérience qui s'inscrit
dans la continuité de la politique menée
par les deux savoie avec le plan ce qui
les projets ne s'arrêtent pas là le
département réfléchit de façon encore
plus avancés à une candidature pour
l'organisation des jo d'hiver 2030
elles sont devenues iconique connu aussi
bien des femmes que des hommes les
semelles rouges louboutin fascine depuis
30 ans le monde entier le travail du
créateur christian louboutin sera
l'objet de la prochaine exposition
estivale du grimaldi forum à monaco à
partir du 9 juillet en attendant l'été
la rédaction de monaco info a voulu en
savoir un peu plus sur les secrets de
fabrication des talons louboutin elle
s'est rendue dans son atelier parisien
un reportage et un témoignage du
créateur rares regardez
donner une femme les bonnes chaussures
et elle pourra conquérir le monde disait
marilyn monroe qui n'a jamais rêvé ne
serait ce que l'espace d'un instant
devant une paire de talons aiguille
siglé christian louboutin en l'espace de
trente ans le créateur parisien a réussi
à imposer sa célèbre semelle rouge à
travers le monde dès l'entrée de
l'atelier une forte odeur de colle s'y
dégage sur les formes en résine des noms
bien connus mais que l'on ne pourra pas
dévoilé on est à l'atelier où on fait
des pères spéciale des perspectives ça
veut dire pour des clientes spécial ça
veut dire pour des projets spéciaux ça
veut dire aussi pour les défilés saveur
donc voilà tout ce qui n'est pas en
séries dans cet atelier 5 paires de
petites mains magiques travail pour
créer le parfum soudé sur mesure c'est
une véritable expérience haute couture
qui est réalisée ici de la prise de
mesures du client à la forme en résine
qui reprend les particularités exacte du
pied jusqu'à la personnalisation à la
main de chaque paire l'atelier niché
derrière une imposante porte cochère de
la rue jean jacques rousseau une rue à
laquelle christian louboutin est très
attaché je me suis installé il ya
exactement trente ans jean jacques
rousseau numéro 19 et puis ensuite et le
21 et le 23 et le 25 à 27 le 29 le 14 de
cinq buts en droit mais plutôt de
changer j'ai trouvé que c'était
important de garder le lieu où tout a
commencé pour moi au niveau mon travail
aujourd'hui le créateur parisien possède
plus de 145 boutiques à travers le monde
véritable savoir faire à la française
depuis le début de l'aventuré louboutin
chaque paire achetée est accompagné de
son cochon rouge et de sa boîte kraft
des éléments qui font l'histoire de la
marque à la semelle rouge depuis trente
ans un travail d'exception qui
continuera de faire rêver pour longtemps
encore et passionnée de mode
et notez donc dans vos agendas
l'exposition consacrée à christian
louboutin au grimaldi forum de monaco à
partir du 9 juillet celui ci est à
découvrir ou redécouvrir à présent le
phare de cordouan a rouvert ses portes
au public en ce mois d'avril le site aux
20000 visiteurs annuels quand même a été
classé en juillet dernier au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco les premiers
touristes de la saison pu découvrir le
fas rénové et embelli par plusieurs
années de travaux un reportage avec
agathe bilstein de la rédaction de télé
7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest
au milieu de l'estuaire de la gironde
dressé sur son plateau rocheux l'unique
phare au monde inscrit au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco chaque année au mois
d'avril il rouvre ses portes au public à
peine arrivé au pied du phare de
cordouan les réactions des premiers
visiteurs sont unanimes de découvrir
juste merveilleux alors là on apprécie
tout neuf quoi type 2 une surprise qui
est assez étonnant mais non c'est
magique ce
chef-d'oeuvre de 64 mètres qu'il faut
préserver pendant 10 saisons d'affilée
chaque centimètre du phare du bâtiment
annulaire à la chapelle en passant par
la lanterne ont été remis quasiment à
neuf un défi pas facile à relever mais
nécessaire le but est d'entretenir avant
de pouvoir restaurer et parfois on est
obligé de combiner les deux vous avez
bien remarqué évidemment que les
conditions sont très difficiles on a du
vent on a du sel on à la houle qui font
que cordon n'est pas un bâtiment comme
les autres il est en pleine mer et donc
on doit intervenir d'autant plus relevée
les pierres les tailles et les sculpter
le travail a été colossal même s'il
reste encore quelques finitions le site
a pu rejoindre la prestigieuse liste des
biens inscrits au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco pour ceux qui ont travaillé sur
le chantier c'est un aboutissement
savoir qu'il a été inscrit après qu'on
ait passé 6 étant ici c'est sûr que
c'est clarifiant encore devant ça reste
je pense que toutes les personnes qui
sont venues travailler ici
l'onl auront en mémoire sacrée bouton
parce que c'est un champion hors norme
des travaux continueront d'avoir lieu
tous les hivers pour entretenir le site
le phare qui brille depuis 1611 n'est
pas près de s'éteindre
restons dans le sud-ouest pour boucler
ce grand jt des territoires avec à
toulouse le début de la neuvième édition
du mr freeze cette exposition géante
d'artistes locaux nationaux ou
internationaux se tient jusqu'au 8 mai
dans la cité rose les oeuvres urbaines
de 70 artistes y sont à découvrir cédric
lastours alias reuzeau graffeurs depuis
30 ans et président du festival nous en
dit un peu plus il est interrogé par
manon aussi du journal la dépêche du
midi nos correspondants sur place on l'a
divisé en deux parties bien distinctes
une ou un peu lâché prise sans risque et
les seuls risques on les a en les avis
très beau recueil est pas de problème
mais où on est tranquille il y aura une
dj au dessus on a mis les lumières qu'il
faut il y aura de la musique on pourra
et danser et faire du sport et regarder
des spectacles et l'autre partie où on
va rentrer dans un contexte un peu
galerie plus cosy où là on va rentrer un
peu dans l'intimité il travail des
artistes des artistes il y en avait dans
l'eau il ya quelques jours dans les
pyrénées orientales les plages de
barcarès accueilli l'une des étapes du
championnat du monde de kitesurf
l'occasion vous le voyez sur ces images
de nos partenaires 2 via occitanie de
s'émerveiller devant des acrobaties
aquatique et aériennes impressionnante à
tous points de vue certaines d'entre
elles ont été exécutées à plus de 15
mètres de hauteur tout simplement
bluffant voilà c'est la fin de ce grand
jt des territoires merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve très vite dans une
prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]